[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y les doy la
bienvenida aquí américa este es el
magazine de france 24 para revisar en
profundidad las noticias y las historias
de nuestro continente y esto es lo que
veremos hoy sigue la pugna por la cumbre
de las américas
el anuncio del anfitrión eeuu de no
tener la intención de invitar a cuba-
venezuela ni a nicaragua por no tener
regímenes democráticos ha desatado una
ola de amenazas de inasistencia de
presidentes con ideologías más o menos
similares encabezados por el mexicano
andrés manuel lópez obrador mientras joe
biden hace concesiones para salvar el
encuentro y el presidente de
estadounidense tiene además que lidiar
con otro problema uno local una nueva
masacre con motivos raciales tuvo lugar
en buffalo en nueva york' la unión
americana tiene un largo historial de
tiroteos motivados por el odio racial
revisamos algunos de ellos y vamos al
sur del continente a argentina donde
conoceremos de la mano de nuestro
corresponsal en buenos aires- a los
clusters influenciadores dedicados a
recomendar libros a los jóvenes a través
de sus redes sociales
y empezamos hablando de la cumbre de las
américas hace una semana les
anunciábamos el boicot al evento de los
ángeles que inició el presidente de
méxico andrés manuel lópez obrador en
rechazo a la intención del anfitrión
eeuu de no invitar a los presidentes de
cuba miguel díaz-canel de nicaragua
daniel ortega y de venezuela nicolás
maduro por no respetar la carta
interamericana de la organización de
estados americanos la oea así lo
anunciaba todo el mandatario mexicano
insiste
con el presidente en baile
y que no se excluye a ningún país de
américa
en la cumbre
del mes próximo a celebrarse en los
ángeles california
y que las autoridades de cada país
decidan libremente
si asisten o no a dicho encuentro pero
que nadie excluya a nadie hoy a pocas
semanas de la fecha prevista para su
inicio en los ángeles del 6 al 10 de
junio no se sabe si el evento tendrá
lugar o si se transformará en una cumbre
de cancilleres miren al boicot iniciado
por habló en nombre de mexico se sumaron
honduras guatemala los 15 países que
integran la comunidad del caribe caricom
y bolivia mientras que naciones como
argentina y chile que ven en naranja en
su pantalla han pedido a la casa blanca
que reconsideren la lista de invitados
que vale la pena recordar aún no ha sido
divulgada oficialmente y en cuanto a los
implicados venezuela ha guardado
silencio
'cuba al inicio de la controversia
afirmó a través del canciller bruno díaz
que se trataba de un retroceso en las
relaciones entre washington y la casa
blanca mientras que daniel ortega dijo
que no le interesaba ir yo le digo de
que haya que olvídense no nos interesa
no interesa
y de esa cumbre
[Aplausos]
en arse
quisiera de llenarse ya seamos de que
esa cumbre no enaltece a nadie
más bien ensucia en barra tenemos que
defenderlo los latinoamericanos para que
nos respeten es una vergüenza realmente
el espectáculo que están dando los
gobernantes yanquis con esta famosa
cumbre crearon la cumbre de la américas
y aparentemente la presión de los varios
países de la región que amenazan con no
asistir a la cumbre californiana está
teniendo efecto en el presidente joe
valdez pues en una serie de movimientos
que cuesta creer que son casualidades la
casa blanca anunció el levantamiento de
algunas sanciones económicas a los
negocios con caracas y en respuesta el
presidente de venezolano nicolás maduro
dijo que estaba listo para retomar las
conversaciones con la oposición con
miras a encontrar una salida a la crisis
que atraviesa el país petrolero y el
mexicano andrés manuel lópez obrador se
ofreció a hacerse de las conversaciones
nuevamente
además yo vaivén flexibilizó de las
medidas contra cuba al reactivar el
programa de reunificación familiar y
levantando el límite de envío de remesas
a la isla veamos más en el siguiente
informe
es una relación de terminar y seguir
pero por ahora las cosas entre cuba y
eeuu se calientan y washington está
flexibilizando su cerco a la economía
cubana ya no habrá límites en las
transferencias de dinero entre ambos
países y a los cubanos que están
tratando de reunirse con sus seres
queridos se les permitirá migrar el
alivio se respira en la habana tenemos
familia en los eeuu y eso representa
mucho pero mucho para los cubanos tener
una ayuda
y no solamente no solamente económica
sino estar abierto que podemos vivir que
podemos que podemos ir hacia allá ellos
venir hacia acá
no obstante estos cambios no coinciden
del todo con las medidas de la
administración obama pero marcan un
freno a las limitaciones impuestas por
el expresidente donald trump la decisión
de bailén de levantarlas es un
movimiento político local pero también
uno democrático es un paso positivo
aunque no es un retorno a la política
obama evidentemente es un rechazo a la
política pero segundo el comunicado del
departamento de estado deja claro que lo
voy a hacer rápido que no van a esperar
las sanciones impuestas por el
presidente kennedy prohíben casi todo el
comercio con cuba y no se prevé que vaya
a ser levantado pronto al mismo tiempo
estados unidos espera tumbar el régimen
comunista que aún está por caer 60 años
después algunos países vecinos reiteran
que las restricciones deben levantarse
por completo yo quisiera que no
hubiera bloqueo
porque eso es
violatorio de los derechos humanos esta
flexibilización trae un respiro a la
economía cubana golpeada por la pandemia
que deja niveles de inflación cercanos
al 70 por ciento
y bueno aunque aún está por verse
quienes asistirán nosotros iremos y los
invitamos a seguir nuestro cubrimiento
especial de la cumbre de las américas
desde los ángeles del 6 al 10 de junio
toda la información del evento en una
sección especial que transmitiremos en
nuestro programa directo américa edición
nocturna de lunes a viernes desde las 19
hasta las 20 45 hora de bogotá quito y
lima vamos ahora a nueva york- a búfalo
que fue escenario de una masacre
motivada por odio racial un joven de 18
años disparó y mató a 10 personas en un
supermercado con el propósito explícito
de atacar a personas afrodescendientes
el presidente estadounidense joe biden
calificó el hecho de terrorismo
doméstico y visitó el lugar del ataque
allí habló también en contra del
supremacismo blanco calificándolo de
veneno en la política de la unión
americana escuchemos sus palabras
la tri de miriam
un odio que a través de los medios de la
política del internet ha llevado a
individuos raciales enojados aislados y
alienados a creer erróneamente que serán
reemplazados por otros
por personas que no se ven como ellos
y llamó a todos los estadounidenses a
rechazar esa mentira
[Música]
y condenó a quienes la divulgan por
poder por ganancia política y por
beneficio en el game center frase
tristemente este tiroteo no es un
incidente aislado en eeuu hay una larga
historia de este tipo de ataques
llevados a cabo por supremacistas
blancos veamos más en el siguiente
informe
los ataques por motivos raciales
aumentaron en eeuu en la última década
la pandemia de ccoo y 19 por ejemplo
alimentó la violencia contra la
comunidad asiática en marzo de 2021 un
hombre de 21 años atacó tres salones de
masaje en atlanta dejando ocho muertos
entre ellos seis mujeres de origen
asiático los activistas afirman que las
declaraciones de donald trump presidente
durante el estallido de la crisis
sanitaria amplificaron el odio
cuando el presidente de eeuu llama al
coronavirus virus de china con flow es
un insulto para todos nosotros los
asiáticos están culpando de un virus que
no tiene nada que ver con nosotros
en agosto de 2019 un hombre que se
declaró un militante de extrema derecha
desató una masacre de 23 personas en un
supermercado en texas le dijo a la
policía que quería matar a todos los
mexicanos posibles un año antes en 2018
un supremacista blanco irrumpió en una
sinagoga de pittsburgh y mató a tiros a
11 personas en el que se convirtió en el
ataque antisemita más mortífero de la
historia del país
está la escena del crimen más horrible
que he visto en 23 años en el fbi los
miembros de la sinagoga árbol de la vida
que realizaban un servicio pacífico en
su lugar de culto fueron brutalmente
asesinados por un hombre armado que los
tenía como objetivo simplemente por su
fe y en junio de 2015 un hombre de 21
años abrió fuego en una iglesia en
carolina del sur apagando la vida de
nueve afroamericanos en los últimos años
la llamada teoría del gran reemplazo ha
ido ganando terreno en eeuu la teoría
racista de la conspiración afirma que la
población blanca sería sustituida
gradualmente hasta su extinción por
inmigrantes no blancos
investigadores de los tiroteos masivos
descubrieron que ha inspirado a varios
autores de ataques
vamos a argentina donde hay un auge de
bloggers youtubers instagramers y tick
tock ers dedicados a recomendar libros
con fotos texto y vídeo pero sobre todo
con una perspectiva muy personal y
orientados a un público
predominantemente juvenil son llamados
los book fluence ers una combinación de
las palabras book libro en inglés e
influencers personas que influyen en
otras el fenómeno es hoy tan grande que
el encuentro debut fluence ers de la
feria del libro de buenos aires fue uno
de los más importantes de todo el evento
anual nuestro corresponsal en buenos
aires- natalio cos hoy nos cuenta más
los protagonistas son los libros pero
también lo son ellos los book clusters
como the words bracho un venezolano de
25 años que llegó argentina en 2015 una
feria del libro de buenos aires y se
terminó quedando con esta cámara que le
regaló a su padre cuando estaba en la
universidad toma fotos para las reseñas
que publica en instagram me gusta
difundir la lectura siento que algo que
a mí me ayudó muchísimo y me encanta que
puedes ir ayudando muchísimo a más
personas a conocer el mundo y a
cambiarle las formas de pensar de muchas
formas posibles
en la feria del libro de buenos aires de
este año the words y otros más de 20
busquen ser se reunieron para verse cara
a cara con su público sería un gran
problema digamos en el ámbito escolar lo
pasaba no la pasaba bien y empecé a leer
y lo vais a pasar hermoso como que
encontré un lugar seguro dentro de los
libros para estar y dije bueno a los
ritmos total
victoria riesco tiene 19 años y comenzó
con sus recomendaciones en redes
sociales durante la pandemia hoy ya
tiene más de un millón doscientos mil
seguidores de sentido que publicó su
primer libro y tiene muy claro el efecto
de lo que hace sobre quienes la siguen
yo creo que hay gente que se cruza con
un músculo de saben nueves y le llama la
atención un libro por esa persona mucha
gente me incisión pesa leer por ojo como
las decenas y decenas que vinieron al
evento varios a ver a victoria gracias a
dicha ley y todo este tiempo y que hubo
por la recomendación de thor y grada que
me gustó mucho y además me gustó su
nombre víctor jácome libros dije otra
persona que come libros como yo crist
alemán y organizadora del evento sigue a
más de una década el fenómeno books en
ser en las confluencias son
facilitadores de lecturas tiene una
ventaja muy grande sobre los adultos la
familia los padres los maestros del
colegio las ventajas que te recomiendan
los padres
y ese vínculo entre pares se ve a las
claras en la dinámica del encuentro de
la feria del libro - una sobre
conferencia y más un diálogo en tono de
fiesta
gracias por acompañarme en esta emisión
de aquí américa en la producción estuvo
giovanni agudelo pueden ver esta emisión
y las anteriores en nuestra página web
france24 puntocom y envíenme sus
comentarios en las redes sociales a la
dirección que ven en su pantalla para
más información de nuestro continente
siguen viendo france24
[Música]